the first agreement on cap reforms was
reached in brussels last winter we were
here at this farm and met eddie pussemia
let's find out what he has to think
about the changes to c.a.p
maximum
farmers will be rewarded for adopting
environmental practices and member
states will have more flexibility in
decision making but with the overall
budget being squeezed by 12
to
373 billion euros could his effect farm
is doing well under the current system
farmers have been asked to do an awful
lot more for an awful lot less money
there's not going to be the same amount
of money around over the next
years and they're going to require to
have more support from the marketplace
the mood amongst member states like
france and the uk has been positive
mep's two welcome measures undertaken to
reform cap
mediating a goodness
of freedom
securing the future of farming is
another key reform young farmers those
under 40 years would be given an
additional 25 percent for the first of
five years on top of their basic payment
a message
final decision on cap reforms will be
taken at the plenary later on this year
with implementation starting in 2014